jessica llegó hace dos meses a bogotá su
familia fue desplazada de un resguardo
indígena embera situado en risaralda una
de las regiones de colombia que sufre la
violencia endémica por el control del
territorio y quiere estar muy peligroso
completo armado por eso
viniste acá y después del gobierno nos
lo han andado bien a ayudarte a
nosotros cuando se el gobierno sí sí le
a francia y después volver a mi tierra y
si no no posee en él sino de gran tierno
a nada volver a tierra como ella más de
1200 indígenas del campamento llevan más
de dos semanas asentados en el céntrico
parque de la capital colombiana para
muchos esta precaria instalación es sólo
una nueva etapa luego de décadas de
desplazamientos forzados por el
conflicto armado el hambre o la
inseguridad
la lideresa nasa violet medina critica
la falta de diálogo con las
instituciones el tema del conflicto
armado ha recrudecido de los territorios
allá si no nos asesinan por un tema de
minería ilegal por un tema de conflicto
armado por el tema del microtráfico
o un tema de cultivos ilícitos
salimos para cuidar la vida a las
ciudades y acá también nos asesinan de
otra forma culturalmente físicamente nos
revictimizan o discriminan o se segregan
13 comunidades indígenas sobreviven aquí
bajo un sol sofocante o el intenso
granizo unas condiciones que han
generado una grave crisis de salud entre
los menores de edad que sufren
enfermedades respiratorias y víricas por
lo que varios han sido hospitalizados y
es que el 60% de los indígenas en el
campamento son niños mujeres embarazadas
y madres lactantes no queremos más
seguir en las calles queremos una vida
digna una casa o sea una vivienda donde
tengamos y de ahí para allá pues
buscamos cómo trabajar cómo producir
según el instituto para el desarrollo y
la paz indepaz más de 240 líderes
indígenas han sido asesinados desde 2016
pese a la firma de los acuerdos de paz
entre el estado y la extinta guerrilla
de las farc las comunidades nativas
continúa sufriendo todas las violencias
del país